géopolitologue gérard vespière fondateur
du site le monde décrypté et chercheur
associé à la fée mot la fondation
d'études pour le moyen-orient
bonsoir gerra vespière merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation egypte jordanie
et donc émirats arabes unis depuis
aujourd'hui une ambassade en israël
concrètement ça change quoi au soir
avoue bien écoutez c'est un
développement qui va dans le sens de
l'apaisement et dans le sens du
rationnel au détriment de l'émotion a je
crois qu'il y à un commentaire
intéressant celui du ministre des
affaires étrangères du bahreïn qui est
aussi a pris la décision d'établir des
relations avec israël qui dit qui a dit
israël fait partie intégrante de
l'histoire de notre région
et quand vous prenez effectivement ce
recul à ce moment là vous avez une
capacité d'apaisement vous avez une
capacité de sagesse il avait une
capacité de dialogue est donc ce qui se
passe avec les émirats arabes unis en
particulier est très intéressant surtout
après 13 années n'est ce pas de
gouvernance netanyahu
on aurait pu croire que donc une
radicalité israélienne très ancré à
droite influence des partis religieux et
bien allait bouleverser dans l'autre
sens
le panorama de la région et bien pas du
tout les émirats arabes unis sont là où
est le pays le plus avancé en termes de
technologie en termes de science en
termes de priorité au rationnel et l'a
donc vous voyez on voit des lignes de
force qui se réunissent à aussi très
enclin à regarder les processus
sociétaux les émirats arabes unis
viennent de sélectionner une femme
astronaute n'est ce pas qui dans un an
va aller dans la station spatiale
internationale
donc on voit comme en israël la foi dans
la science la fois dans la passe et
rationnelle là on parle des émirats
arabes unis mais on l'a dit il ya
l'egypte et la jordanie il ya d'autres
pays
également qu'ils veulent normaliser
leurs relations avec israël en tous les
cas ça a été initiée sous le mandat de
donald trump
mais sans parler que des émirats arabes
unis ici parlons plus généralement du
monde arable gérard vespière qu'elle
plus à gagner dans ses rôles dans la
normalisation de ses relations
diplomatiques
alors vous avez évoqué l'histoire avec
la jordanie et l'egypte il ya aussi bien
sûr le maroc qui est en train de
normaliser ses hoquets décidé de
normaliser ses relations aussi dont la à
la une volonté de dialogue et qui dit
dialogue dit apaisement est aussi
incitations pour l'autorité
palestinienne et bien de rentrer dans ce
jeu du rationnel de quitter le champ de
l'émotionnel de la fibre et et donc du
conflit et je crois que derrière ce
décor diplomatique qui s'élargit à bon
nombre de pays a dû la de la région donc
beaucoup de pays arabes à venir
probablement le koweit aussi donc il
bien se le dise quitter le champ du
conflit mais quelles conséquences au
final pour la région parce qu on se
souvient des quand même eu un gros
affrontement ya pas très longtemps onze
jours de conflit un qui a fait 260 morts
entre israël et le hamas dernièrement
alors je me référais à nouveau à ce même
ministre des affaires étrangères du
bahreïn qui a dit nous avons un
adversaire commun l'iran est donc ce que
vous venez d'évoquer ce n'est pas tant
le hamas qui a décidé ce n'est pas le
hamas qui s'est fabriqué 4160 roquettes
n'est ce pas elles sont deux conceptions
iranienne donc face aussi un adversaire
régional commun eh bien vous avez une
organisation diplomatiques politiques
des pays arabes et d'israël qui est
aussi est confronté à l'iran mais quelle
plus à perdre au final ce ne sont pas
les palestiniens quelle réaction de
l'autorité palestinienne à tout ça je
pense pas qu'il faille raisonner en
termes de perte du spa la grande perte
que nous avons dans cette région c'est
l'absence de dialogue c'est l'absence de
bon sens a donc tout ce qui peut amener
et la relation diplomatique est la base
du dialogue et la base de l'analyse et
la base du bon sens et bien c'est un
plus à terme pour l'autorité
palestinienne qui doit s'éloigner
effectivement et qui s'éloignera si
l'iran ou le régime iranien périclite
progressivement
eh bien vous verrez le hamas aussi
péréclité progressivement et quelle
réaction de la communauté internationale
à ce jeu de normalisation des relations
entre israël et les pays arabes on
al'impression ça passe un peu au second
plan et que les médias en parlent peu
pourquoi fait qu'en france parce que en
france n'est ce pas les relations
internationales ne sont pas le fort de
notre pays en termes de médiatisation
il y a très peu de place dans les médias
en général à cette rubrique a donc mais
on ne peut que se réjouir de ce
processus qui va dans le sens de
l'histoire et qui devrait
progressivement avec le temps car on
vient de loin ne sais pas 1947 et bien
avec le temps on ira vers l'apaisement
et une solution merci gérard vespière
voir répondu à nos questions je rappelle
que vous êtes spécialiste du
moyen-orient vous êtes chercheur associé
à la fée - la fondation d'études pour le
moyen-orient
vous êtes aussi le fondateur du site le
monde décrypté